prosecutors in Massachusetts dropped a
charge of indecent assault against actor
Kevin Spacey now this comes after
Spacey's alleged victim refused to
testify the man's family say they are
very disappointed with the prosecutors
decision CTM national correspondent
tarika Duncan has been following this
case from the very beginning no lady not
the man accusing actor Kevin Spacey of
indecent assault and battery said the
cell phone he used that night in 2016
contained incriminating text messages
and videos his mother testified earlier
this month he had shot a video of Kevin
Spacey sticking his hand inside his
pants but the now 21 year-old who was 18
at the time later told authorities he
lost the phone last week he pleaded the
fifth Amendment when defense attorneys
reminded him that altering evidence like
manipulating screenshots is illegal
those texts are not in the screenshots
CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman if
you have a complaining witness who is
allegedly a sexual assault victim who is
claiming the Fifth Amendment and
therefore is not going to testify what
have you got you've got nothing the
district attorney filed a motion to drop
the case against Spacey citing the
unavailability of the complaining
witness the accusers family disagreed
with that move the fact that the
prosecution has decided not to go
forward in no way says that Kevin Spacey
has been exonerated the prosecution was
simply faced with a case that by virtue
of the alleged victim taking the Fifth
Amendment they didn't have a witness to
say what happened we reached out to
Spacey's attorney for comment but have
not heard back the actor is not out of
legal jeopardy completely he reportedly
is still facing sexual assault
allegations and Great Britain this is
the prosecutors decision not the family
correct the family was disappointed by
this they wanted to move forward you
know when we spoke to Heather Unruh two
years ago she felt like the me2 movement
this was the time to come out with
whatever had
gone on and felt as though the
victim-blaming was was over in terms of
culturally so she's upset all right Joe
Rica thank you